[Music]
6 25 on your labor day monday what's
driving you crazy how about temporary
headaches on the road to
improved pedestrian safety in downtown
las vegas here's the deal the city of
las vegas is kicking off nine months of
work aimed at making fremont street and
the surrounding downtown area safer for
pedestrians so
starting tomorrow morning running
weekdays from seven in the morning to
three in the afternoon
to focus on three particular
intersections along fremont
at main street at first and at fourth
the city says when they're all done the
area will have enhanced
bollard security street lighting traffic
signals
all to go along with better pedestrian
sidewalks
so this is a this part of the project is
expected to wrap up in january of next
year
then the focus shifts to two other
fremont street intersections at casino
center in third
as well as nearby first and stuart you
have to watch out for lane restrictions
and you're going to need to expect
delays during the work hours
the city suggests either casino center
or maryland parkway's workarounds
now all of this information it's on our
website 8newsnow.com you click traffic
then driving you crazy
if there is something driving you crazy
email me with pictures and video please
to traffic 8 8newsnow.com